je veux ap avec attractions un joueur
michael jackson lui aussi eu cette idée
sauf qu'il avait les thunes pour la
réaliser pas moi mais j'ai études pour
acheter un jeu pour faire un pas
d'infraction c'est long on a battu le
record de longueur de la toile plus
besoin je parle vite pour désamorcer je
vous présente squeeze dans 20 ans voilà
qu évident sur youtube et qui serait mis
au vin rouge que son aura triplé de
volume et qui seraient obèses
la bonne nouvelle dans l'histoire c'est
que je n'aurai pas de calvitie allez
c'est parti on a créé un matin je me
bats comme sa soeur on ne veut pas le
mec qu'elle part qu'il est dans l'ombre
il est là il encaisse des billets c'est
tout alors objectif attiré 800 visiteurs
et construire deux attractions déjà qui
sont ces gens qui tirent sur la foule
n'a pas ou quoi vous êtes vous voulez
faire fuir les clients ok donc le
parquet minuscule un finalement il n'est
pas très grand
il est même minuscule là on à
l'attraction du coup pour les bébé cadum
ah je sais que t'es pas entendu ce mot
depuis très longtemps mais est ce que je
peux faire une attraction ici ici c'est
très propre et ses attractions aller
qu'est ce qu'on a
le white blue est les gens ils vont
kiffer ça m'a dit je vais mettre là un
mode osef web est juste à côté de
l'autre voilà comme ça ils n'ont pas
besoin de beaucoup marcher pour y aller
en place et en place c'est incroyable
cette action ferme et pourquoi il faut
que je fasse l'entrée elle est là ok
placer la sortie on va être la sortie
ici ok et relais l'entrée à l'aller bah
c'est très simple allez c'est parti ça
ouvre le white blue vient d'ouvrir
mesdames et messieurs à regarder il
court il court pour la faire au mod all
when you c'est génial sa nouvelle
attraction sur les haies par squeeze
second fils de [ __ ] faiblissement
produit c'est incroyable on y va est-ce
que ça s'envole en rien et elle est
heureuse
prix du billet 9 dollars
voilà un petit plus 50% tranquille des
grosses parts allez on va continuer à en
faire une attraction qu'est ce qui peut
attirer les gens ça c'est nul c'est nul
c'est nul ça c'est quoi c'est bien ça
évalués par la pop on est bons l'entrée
on va la mettre juste devant le tuc
aguicher vraiment payer payet bande de
[ __ ] le client est roi chez squeeze
industrie allez ça ouvre sa housse est
parti c'est la fiesta loca bébés
allaités jusque là les amis faut que je
mette un petit stand de nourriture type
on voit sa tirelire boutiques et
services qu'est-ce qu'on encaisse conte
à grande-entrée conte de fées ben voilà
ben voilà c'est ça il faut pour attirer
les gens comme ça voilà au maire
germany's spams ont double-cliquant
qu'ils sont déplacés spyder est vrai
bien croyez moi un nom quitter une fête
foraine donc de tuer être calmes et
aller les gens à les y aurait il ya un
beau château vous êtes attirés de ouf
et encore j'ai pas monter plus de
billets de la deuxième attraction bon
bref ça c'est réussi le mode cas c'est
bien mais franchement ce pour les
débutants bah oui le parc il est déjà à
moitié fait nous on veut du défi et ça
tombe bien parce qu'une catégorie des
fip ou comment son parc à zéro et on n'a
pas de thunes illimitée on fait ça dans
quoi alpes s prairies moi je pense d'eux
mais c'était désertiques comme ça il n'y
a pas d'eau et on vend l'oip recherche
on devient riche aléas des c'est juste
un chemin de fer joggi on vient de loin
quand même
est-ce qu'on commence par juste faire
des stats de bouffe mec montagnes russes
à kout 4038 on a combien d'argent 4000
whaou
j'ai pas tant il est énorme le truc ça
ça coûte 3500 $ ça mais je fais dans mon
jardin direct hockey atome elle est
carrément bien ça à faire fureur
il ya des gens qui viennent ou pas je
suis la personne qui vient ma personne
bien mais comment j'attire les gens
aillent à deux personnes ça y est ils
s'étaient perdus il faisait un petit
rally sont crashés il marche et donc sur
quoi mon parc d'attractions à je vais
les mettre bien là files d'attentes pour
the madness à la rapide et ya personne
dans mon parc à thème un pichet mille
entrées devant des bancs du collège à
monza en jambes et le ventre et or l'art
nfaa les motifs
[Musique]
non mais non j'ai fait un truc nickel et
j'ai plus de thunes peau j'ai plus
d'argent pour finir ces escaliers qui
permet d'accéder aux [ __ ] de n'a fait
faillite c'est reparti ok là vous n'êtes
pas un truc génial et jean les arrivées
rang dans le parc tout de suite la file
de droite claque c'est direct pour la
fille l'attend parce que tu veux tout de
suite faire l'attraction quand tu
arrives n'a pas envie de voir mickey
faire comment ça non et je me dirais que
le prix à 12 parce que les gars c'est le
début aussi soyez compréhensifs quand on
sera une fille multimilliardaire de parc
d'attractions je vais célébrer le début
ok l'attraction ouvre et là on accélère
le temps c'est parti oh mon dieu ils
arrivent ils arrivent ils arrivent
vous voyez ces gens nous on voit pas des
gens en on voit des billets qui volent
dans mon décès en train de faire de
l'argent c'est en train de faire de
l'argent c'est en train de faire du gros
bénéfices sa mère je suis comme un fou
au [ __ ] mon gars ont fait fureur avec
une attraction c'est exceptionnel et là
attention qu'est ce qu'on fait on
repasse en vitesse normale et on va tout
de suite construire un petit stand de
vous elle a sorti la traction qu'est ce
qu'ils mangent de la boue et tulle avons
mis notre action d'après du coup tant
rachète deux fois plus de bénéfices deux
fois plus d'argent
voilà on va mettre le petit tube if un
peu pourri ce ça continue de faire de
l'argent ou par là les gens ils en
disent quoi ouais c'est cool ça marche
ça cartonne donc ça s'est fait ensuite
font un truc de des toilettes étaient
hyper important ya pas des toilettes
normale et objet de faire des toilettes
à thème genre tout et pirate toilettes
conte de fées ya cendrillon dans les
toiles à côté non bon bozo le clown
s'est plaint mais c'est flippant mais
moi jamais jamais vu ou vécu dans cet
endroit jamais alors files d'attentes
maintenant c'est rapide je pense que je
peux rajouter un wagon mec mais j'ai
peur de le faire mais bon je ferme la
traction messieurs dames c'est pour
votre bien
et j'ajoute deux wagons et je n'arrive à
la tanche obligé de la testa von arx et
ouvrir n'en portait pas partez pas ou
alors vous pouvez faire une petite pause
à la buvette elle est vraiment cool
umberger ya pas de soucis allez-y
en ont ils rentrent chez eux [ __ ] de
merde c'est bon c'est ouvert vous
prévenir
robert van de putte le client est roi
chez squeeze industries annonce ils
partent vraiment puis partie de
déménagement j'avais vu des gens aussi
pressé de partir ok ya du monde qui
arrive c'est bon on est bien l'étude
reviennent l'étude reviennent bon faut
que tu fasses des toilettes mais capable
rien va faire le village de conte de
fées c'est payant les chiottes a tancé
pas payant sap à nous rapporter d'argent
ou wop pow pow j'ai failli faire une
bêtise là tout ce qui n'apporte pas
d'argent dégage bien loin oh les gars le
moment tant attendu est arrivé on va
pouvoir faire le white blue bottes hop
on va le mettre là relier l'entrée à
l'aller c'est très simple juste à côté
des chiottes comme ça dans la file
d'attenté gars vous allez kiffer les
odeurs voilà ils rendent par là il
ressort par là et ça dégage c'est très
très bien les mecs je suis content ça
commence à ressembler à quelque chose ou
pas hein on a les petites chiottes la
bouffe deux attractions l essentiel est
là ça c'est vraiment le truc a fait
fureur quoi vraiment les gens ils sont
hyper contents ils se madness est en
panne eux en panne
qu'est ce que je dois faire demander une
rénovation à l'évasion rénovons rénovons
anovo manoeuvre aux mecs c'est la fin du
monde
[ __ ] heureusement qu'on a la deuxième
je comprends pas ils rénovent ou pas
j'ai dit rénover la satisfaction des
moyennes visiteurs baisse bah oui mais
la taxe ne tombe en panne comme enjeu
dans les normes pourquoi il rénove pas
le mec met du temps à venir salle mais
le mec fait un ratio met du temps à
venir ça qui se passe pas un mec
sinon je la vends un genre fait une mais
je vais faire ça mais si je la vends
voilà the madness
en plus il m'a rapporté plus que ce qui
coûte à non écoute 4000 ans le qu'on
parle je leur fais je leur fais je le
fais mais que ça va plus vite
oui awesome as les couilles nous aimer
comme ça allait on l'a testé on la
relance de la fin je pense aller plus
vite mais le guen et dans les bouchons
moi je dit gâtés bouchon c'est quoi ça
appuie dont on conçoit l'attraction que
d'attendre que tu sors des bouchons
créés à flight détritus [ __ ] l'enculé
de gros porc j'ai mis des chiottes l'a
jamais des chiottes là vous jetez les
choses [ __ ] mais allez crever le
client est roi chez sa cousine du street
bon du coup j'ai employé v'là les
mécaniciens là pour la fin du mois et ça
me piquer au niveau du prix mais ce parc
au moins là je peux réparer les trucs en
2 2 madness coûte trop cher mais arrêtez
vos conneries madness coûte pas trop
cher du tout la vache ça coûte super
cher à merde rennes manescu trop cher
c'est bon allez on va le mettre à 12,7 à
on est pas mal [ __ ] à l'argent entre
la bon les gars il va être temps de
mettre une autre attraction va pas se
mentir
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir se mettre
c'est un truc un peu familial tu vois
psycho la ba voila up et voilà et on
ouvrait au niveau des thunes 6 dollars
c'est pas assez on va mettre neuf voilà
c'est parti
les gains ont commencé à trois
attractions deux toilettes un
distributeur de billets anja paerson les
gens les ignorent lycées 8 heures
parfait rénove
on va tout rénové pourquoi personne
rénove la bon les gars vous rénovez
koala a tancé la chute là je comprends
plus je suis en train de perdre
l'argent mes voyages en perte à cause de
sacs et ferney j'ai demandé une
rénovation rénové bordel l'om c'est que
j'ai pris trop d'employés là j'en ai
pris trop pour qu'il répare mais il
répare pas on est en train de mener à
notre perte sur train de mener à notre
perte mayday mayday twenty two mail et
wendy tous très bien
ça fait maintenant quatre heures et demi
que j'ai demandé la passion de la
traction mais l'ingénieur qu'est ce
qu'il fait il se balade dans le parc aux
fonds dégagés fond des âges et les
payeurs qui voit sa paye tout fonds
dégagés
toi tu fais quoi né à thé verrais tu
sortes ta en perdre trop d'argent les
gens ils sont pas contents les toilettes
sont vides les déchets par terre
un rêve qui se brise malgré tous ses
efforts squeeze de pu sauver son parc
d'attraction c'est la conclusion un peu
nul de cette vidéo vous attendez à ce
que je dise autre chose
mais je n'ai rien à ajouter et moi j'en
suis apprentie vidéo sur planète on
stage passionnant puisque est bilingue
d'habitude je pense faire vite n'était
pas là mais ça va plus ça me fait marrer
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
jouer à un jeu comme ça une simulation
ou quand j'étais petit je jouais à
sauviat zoo tycoon je crois ou si tu
fais un [ __ ] de l'eau avec des animaux
j'adore j'adore les animaux je n'ai pas
dit assez cette semaine avec le mp3 ou
faisaient pas compris j'adore les
animaux et bien mais ça vous regarde et
peut-être qu'on ferait un deuxième
épisode où cette fois on ne construira
pas dans le désert non non non les gens
le désert ils sont vénère ils ont chaud
ils sont déshydratés il transpire ça
plus non non on le fera en antarctique
attaquant gedo le savoyard né merci
d'avoir payé pour venir dont pas une
traction je vous dis à très
prochainement
[Musique]